alison has already been introduced so I
won't repeat that introduction I'll just
add one thing in her role as the chair
of the US Nuclear Regulatory Commission
I believe if I got this correctly she
was the first earth scientists to hold
that role so for fellow or scientists
very good well done Allison yeah I was
actually the first commissioner ever to
be a geologist on the and maybe the last
who knows and I don't know if you
realize how many or scientists you were
inviting today but you did get quite a
few of us and I am going to be talking
from an earth science perspective so I
want to focus as i said earlier on
safety and especially in light of the
Fukushima accident and sort of bring us
up to where we are now we've talked
about a number of these issues already
some of the problems facing the nuclear
industry we just talked about on the
previous panel the economic situation
competition from natural gas the reduced
electricity demand actually we didn't
talk about that so much but a lot of the
part of the country where there are a
lot of nuclear power plants was hit very
hard by the recession in addition to
which there's been a fair bit of
population movement away from those
areas so the the demand has really gone
down there there are difficulties in new
build we talked about that a bit the
high capital costs the long construction
times and the restructure electricity
markets we talked about that talked
about nuclear waste disposal previously
and safety we've talked about that a
little bit but I think especially the
credibility of the changes that are put
in place after the Fukushima accident
are very important and so I want to
focus on that and what I what I'll do
because we haven't talked about the
Fukushima accident today is bring walk
you through a little bit of what
happened from a geologist perspective in
part and then talk about some of the
lessons that were learned what we think
were some of the contributing factors to
the accident and some of the changes
that are being made or in my view
should be made so that's that's how I'm
going to go forward so again let's start
from a geologist point of view what
happened at Fukushima long march 11 2011
there was a massive 9.0 earthquake off
the east coast of Japan you can see the
epicenter there just northeast of Sendai
and in terms of the Tohoku quake we
think of I think of this geologically it
was caused by essentially the Pacific
plate which is being subducted
underneath the North American plate and
the earthquake occurred in that
subduction zone and it resulted in
actually huge for what we see it usually
on a quake by quake basis a huge amount
of land motion so let me give you more
of a sense of this and I don't know if
you want to dim the lights for this is a
little movie okay that will give you a
sense of the earthquake and the area
around Japan alright so let me just tell
you this is um can you hear ya so these
these the sizes of the circles relate to
the magnitude of the earthquake and you
can see and you can hear it too alright
and the radius the direction of the
radius points to the depth of the
earthquake and so now you're going to
see map of Japan and these are the
earthquakes that are occurring you can
see does this pointer work yes so here's
the subduction zone I was talking about
and here on earth quakes happening
around Japan and this is January the
15th the 16 the 17th so we're marching
in time in 2011 and you're getting a
sense of the amount of earthquake
activity Japan is one of the most
actively seismically active places on
the planet and you're getting a bit of a
sense of that you can see a lot of the
quakes are associated with the
subduction zones
and you can't hear it that well I don't
know where the volume is but anyway okay
so now we're in February I just want you
to look out for a few precursor
earthquakes for shocks that occurred
just before the massive nine-point-oh
and those four shocks occur there about
magnitude 6 or 7 narrower in March okay
look for the four shots there are the
four shocks that was and these are the
aftershocks watch the days go by and the
intense activity of the aftershocks if
you can whoops oh no sorry huh if you
can if you could read that that that
that this goes this has its own mind
sorry to ruin the movie
right that's where our aftershocks here
so this yellow line is showing you the
number of earthquakes and you can see
this is March 11th when the number of
earthquakes increases dramatically and
these show you the magnitudes of the
quakes and when they occur these are
just the big quakes that's listening and
you know you're in April and I'm not
going to run this the whole way because
this goes basically through almost the
end of the year but this kind of
activities maintained for a long time so
with such a massive earthquake there are
lots of aftershocks so just wants you
two to get that that sense okay not
significant so there was but that's a
good segue into the next slide here
there was significant some significant
damage in terms of roadways etc
buildings that were built to code were
actually in fairly good shape as a
result of that earthquake it was
offshore a bit I remember reading some
headlines at the time in Tokyo saying oh
this was the big one for Tokyo and no it
was not the big one for Tokyo Tokyo was
quite far away over 250 kilometers away
the big one for Tokyo is yet to come but
nonetheless older buildings did not
survive very well but the plant lost
off-site power so electricity was lost
to a lot of places but of course worse
was the because of the large land
subsidence in this in the ocean there
was a huge tsunami that was created as a
result okay the tsunami arrived on the
shores of japan between about 30 minutes
to 60 minutes after the earthquake and
this is the tsunami arriving near
fukushima where it arrived within 50
minutes of the earthquake and the
tsunami waters at the Fukushima Daiichi
reactor site were about 14 to 15 meters
high as 45 feet for those of you who
don't translate and that's incredibly
high
so what happened let me just give you a
sense of the site itself and the tsunami
waters and crouching on the site so this
is part of the site note the van here
and use that to give you a sense of
scale for these two tanks this is 342
p.m. okay one minute later the tanks are
gone well they're there they're just
under water so it was inundated almost
instantly okay and that's really yeah
thanks that's better and that really is
is quite impressive and part of the
problem for the Fukushima site is there
they lost the off-site power and you
have to realize the thing about nuclear
energy is that although it exists to
produce electricity it can't exist
without electricity because you need to
keep the at least the plants that we've
designed you need to keep water on those
reactor cores you need to keep pumping
water through so you need to to have a
source of energy to do that and usually
you rely on off-site power to do that
but when you lose off-site power which
happens you have backup diesel
generators the backup diesel generators
were in the basements and so were their
fuel supplies so as a result you all
know this three of the reactor units
melted down they generated hydrogen in
the process they experienced a number of
massive explosions which resulted in
damage to the building such as you see
on the right here that's a unit three
the site itself of course because of the
tsunami not only did they lose off-site
power and there was just debris all over
the place when I was there I went to the
site in December 2012 there was still
debris all over the place which is
pretty impressive for Japan
because they usually clean things up
pretty quickly I'll be going there and
in a few weeks and I'm interested to see
if some of that debris is still there
and here's just a perspective of the
site this is after the accident you can
see unit four unit three unit one all
with their tops blown off unit two
suffered a explosion but inside the
plant and you can see this is just all
debris all over the place so it's a was
a mess of course these meltdowns and
subsequent releases of
radiation-contaminated the nearby towns
this is the the Tomioka train station a
whole rail line had to be abandoned
because of high radiation towns were
deserted probably permanently a number
of them the only winner here is the
weeds which have now taken over a lot of
these places so this is a map of the
Fukushima site here and you can see the
prevailing winds actually they were very
lucky with this accident because most of
the prevailing winds were out to sea so
most of the radiation went out to see
the vast majority did at some point in
time the winds turned around and they
did go inland and in that direction ok
this first circle is 20 kilometers the
second circle is 30 kilometers people
out to 20 kilometers were evacuated and
the problem of course with these
circular evacuation zones is that the
window noise travels in one direction so
one area is contaminated and the other
isn't so what happened is that people
went from relatively clean areas and
they evacuated into the danger zone
without knowing it and without the
government being told telling them so
they you know put themselves in danger
now this is actually a over a year old
now but the exclusion areas have been
shrinking so the green and everything
orange were exclusion areas they've now
been freed up to some degree there will
remain some exclusion areas which I
think will last for
a long time a 160,000 people were moved
because of this and lost their jobs and
livelihoods etc I do want to say that
they have been making progress cleaning
up the site this is unit four on the
left here shortly after the accident you
can see still pumping water into the
spent fuel pool which is the top of the
building i'll show you a little figure
later explaining that this is in
december 2012 when i was there they'd
actually cleared off a lot of the debris
on top and we actually got to walk on
top of the reactor they have now this
was before and after they put on an
entire new roof on unit 4 and they as of
the end of december had moved all the
spent fuel that was in that pool on unit
42 a common pool that was quite a feat
and they're planning on doing this now
for unit 3 spent fuel pool they're
working through these reactors okay so
what were some of the causes of the
accident well as I said loss of off-site
power from the earthquake and then of
course the backup equipment was below
ground and was drowned basically they
were cut off from outside assistance
because of the damage from the
earthquake and they had poor
communications because you know of the
of the earthquake damage as well Japan
itself did a number of very critical
reports about the accident one of the
most critical was done by the Japanese
diet which basically blamed Japan and
the Japanese system for the accident
they said it was a result of collusion
between the regulator and the government
and TEPCO the utility that ran the power
plant they blamed Japanese culture
especially the reluctance to question
authority which in the United States we
value very highly we call that safety
culture and we actually evaluate the
Nuclear Regulatory Commission evaluates
plants for their safety culture it's
important part of what we do and so that
was it was quite a damning report I
think there are a variety of
contributing factors
to this accident I don't think you can
point to one specific thing and say it
was their fault and the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission when asked you
know could a similar accident happen in
the United States they said us
regulations would not have prevented a
similar accident in the United States
why is that well that's because nobody
not the u.s. not any other regulator in
any other country ever contemplated more
than one reactor melting down at once
this was new we now have to think about
this and we now have to be prepared for
this and we hadn't considered certain
what are called beyond design basis
natural events so Japan had not
considered such a massive tsunami
potentially occurring in fact they had
not considered such a massive earthquake
occurring and that's because the
seismology hadn't gotten to that point
until after the sumatra earthquake in
2004 at the end of two thousand four so
i can talk about that later if you're
interested so let's talk a little bit
more about what else we learned from
Fukushima so on the on the right is a
little diagram of the kind of reactor
that exists at Fukushima this is a
boiling water reactor a general electric
not Westinghouse we had Westinghouse
here Oh boiling water a general electric
boiling water reactor of the mark-1
design okay and what you're looking at
here the red is the reactor vessel okay
that's where the fuel is and this sort
of erlenmeyer flask you can see I did
science shaped area is called a
containment okay and this is a concrete
steel reinforced structure that
hopefully will contain any kind of
radioactivity that leaks out of the
reactor vessel that worked during the
three-mile acts three mile island
accident that protected us from Three
Mile Island it did not work at Fukushima
and what one thing to note here is that
the containment is is very small you
don't know this because if you unless
you're a nuclear engineer but you know
pressurized water reactors have much
larger containments so if the
containment itself gets pressurized
there's a lot more space to to handle
that pressure increase in pressure so
one thing that was noted by many
including the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission is that the small containment
cinmarc one and mark to design reactors
pose particular challenges especially
with venting and so that has to be
addressed there are ways to vent these
containments to release that pressure
but they're right now designed very
difficult to get to I've been to some of
them and crawled around you really have
to crawl around in the bowels of these
buildings and climb over all sorts of
equipment and you can try to imagine
doing that under the higher accident
conditions that would exist during an
accident so and another another thing
that became a real issue during the
Fukushima accident was the spent fuel
pool which you can see is all the way up
here and there was a question especially
for unit 4 which had the most and the
freshest hottest spent fuel in it as to
whether it was boiling off that water
because the spent fuel pools need also
act of circulation of water so there
they need that electricity and so there
was a lot of money spent and a lot of
sweat spent trying to decide whether
that spent fuel pool on unit for had
boiled off that water or not because if
it had there was a high potential for
large radioactive release so that's
another another lesson so what were some
of the responses and these are responses
made not just by the United States the
Nuclear Regulatory Commission here but
by the French and by the Germans and by
the British and everybody and the
Japanese as well so obviously you need
backup equipment and
you need emergency backup equipment
distributed around the site in the
United States we required additional
backup equipment distributed around the
site that you have to be able to handle
more than one reactor having a problem
in distress at one time and you also
have to have backup equipment that could
be brought into the plant within 24
hours and so what you're looking at here
is a brand-new facility in Phoenix
Arizona to service the western part of
the country where they have backup
diesel generators backup pumps piping
fuel supplies that can be brought and
already there you can see there on truck
beds they can be brought within a very
short time to a plant and they also had
to standardize all the connections so
that the pipe fittings would would work
and so that's what the US nuclear
industry has been working on over the
past few years another response was to
reevaluate some of these natural hazards
that I talked about and so the u.s. in
particular has been involved in
reevaluating seismic hazards this is a
seismic hazard map for the US based on
new seismic source analyses that were
done in the earlier 2000s so the u.s.
plants are in the process of doing this
they're also in the process of
re-evaluating flood hazards and
eventually may get to look at other
kinds of hazards projectiles from
tornadoes hurricane-force winds that
kind of thing other issues again back to
those events that we we talked about
they need to be opened remotely you
don't want to send somebody crawling
around the bowels of the plant in a
completely dark plant that has high
radiation areas so that's being worked
on and you should be able to these vents
should be able to operate under the high
temperature pressure and radiation
conditions that would occur during an
accident an area that many countries
have added but the US has decided not to
so far is to add a filter to that vent
so when you vent those gases which
contain a lot of radioactivity and there
was some delay inventing the gases from
the Japanese plan
in part because of concerns about the
contamination that would be caused by
venting those plants you can add a
filter and that filter is essentially a
tank of water that you run a pipe
through and like I said many other
countries did this as a result of the
Chernobyl accident and now as a result
of Fukushima almost all except as far as
i can tell slovakia and the u.s. have
decided to add filters to their plants
so another common response and again i
mentioned that before so another another
area i think that we need to consider
now this is now my points of view some
countries are working on this some not
but communication so during the accident
there was a lack of communication in
part it was caused by not an inability
to communicate but in part it was caused
by it wasn't clear who was in charge and
so the Japanese government wasn't
getting good information the Japanese
public certainly wasn't getting much
information and and the international
community was getting very little
information people from the UM Nuclear
Regulatory Commission were sent
immediately to Japan upon learning of
the accident to the US Embassy there and
it took I don't know weeks for them to
establish good lines of communication to
figure out what was going on to be able
to to help out and I just want to give
you an example of this I talked I
alluded to this earlier when I spoke
earlier but as a result of this
confusing information the and the
concern about that spent fuel pool in
particular and the lack of information
people were doing worst-case analyses
and recommending you know to their
governments what they should do about
their people because it wasn't just the
Japanese involved there were quite a few
US citizens their Canadian citizens we
had a number of ships military ships off
the Navy ships off the coast we needed
to advise them on whether they were safe
or not and the u.s. decided to tell
their folks to evacuate out
to 80 kilometers 50 miles and just to
remind you this is 20 30 this is 60
kilometers and this is 80 kilometers
okay at 65 kilometers is the town the
city of Fukushima which can has over
300,000 people the Canadians followed
the US and recommended evacuation out to
80 France actually told their people in
Tokyo to evacuate so you wonder about
the difference between regulators there
you go and Japan again as I said
immediately after the accident out 23
kilometers within another day out to 20
and then they told people between 20 and
30 kilometers to shelter in place and in
part I think they were concerned about
trying to evacuate a city of 300,000 so
this just led to confusion and also
diplomatic troubles there were also
communications that were concerning to
the Japanese public the they changed the
allowed doses to workers and that sort
of makes sense because they have a
crisis scenario catastrophe that one I
think people can live with that change
but what the public could not live with
was this one that the dose two children
was increased from allowable dose from 1
millisievert to 20 and that I think did
a lot of damage to the Japanese public
sense of trust of the government and the
nuclear industry after the accident
there was also a lot of communication
confusion that we experienced here in
the United States on the right here is a
little map of the plume as I said most
of the radiation went out to sea well
that eventually was going to come to the
United States a lot of radiation went
into the water even this is one of the
more conservative models of radiation
coming out from Japan the plume coming
over to the US this is arriving here
about last year
and then dissipating over time and so
there's been a lot of confusion about
that why because there has been almost
no data collection you know how do you
know how do you confirm well you go out
there and you actually take water
samples and measure and there was late
coordination among government agencies
we started getting questions while I was
at the Nuclear Regulatory Commission oh
you know should I be worried you know
what's this the radiation coming other
other folks at other agencies were
getting these kinds of questions but
there was little coordination eventually
they did pull together and there's a lot
of misinformation on the web you know
YouTube videos of guys with Geiger
counters at a beach in California
measuring you know background
differences and saying oh my god it's
here you know you have to run anyway one
guy one guy really has gone out there
and had been trying to do a lot of work
dr. ken buesseler of the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution he's the one
person who's been doing some objective
measurements of what's going on out
there and let me just assure you that
any radiation coming to us Shores is two
orders of magnitude so you know a
hundred times less than the drinking
water standard so it's really nothing to
worry about but it is measurable I think
other other additional considerations
should be economic consequences from the
accident and I'll say at the outset that
I don't think counting prompt deaths
contrary to what we heard this morning
is really relevant frankly and that's
because what what happened in Japan and
certainly what happened at Chernobyl is
a large loss of land use a loss of water
use the fishing industry around
Fukushima is destroyed the agricultural
industry is destroyed as I said 160,000
people evacuated lost their homes lost
their livelihoods there were extreme
psychological effects that persists to
this day they lost their they lost
thirty percent of their electricity
supply and we're now in 2015 four years
after the accident they don't have it
back and if it comes back it
slow and they of course lost the
investment at the site so these are huge
losses that aren't life losses they're
not dead people but they're extremely
relevant and radiation can affect other
countries and the Chernobyl accident you
see a map of the radiation from the
Chernobyl accident that radiation went
over a thousand kilometers and it
affected not just the area around
Chernobyl but the it affected the
reindeer herders in the in Sweden and
Finland it affected the sheep farmers in
the United Kingdom they couldn't use
their sheep because their sheep were
contaminated so this you know and the
this issue of radiation affecting other
countries is is especially relevant I
think for countries in the European
Union and they're very concerned about
that and I think that's you know I
talked earlier about the Convention on
nuclear safety and some of the changes
that were attempted there that feeds
into into that sense another thing I
think we need to put some forethought
into is if you have an accident how are
you going to clean it up because
watching the experience at Japan has
been very eye-opening you need a place
to deal with contaminated water you need
a place to put the contaminated
materials you better have a plan for
that waste this is the Fukushima site
here are the damaged reactors right
these things are all water tanks why are
they water tanks well they pull off four
hundred metric tons of water a day and
that water is contaminated they pull it
out from the basement why well it's a
sighting issue the basements of these
facilities are slightly below the water
table yeah oh so this is what you can't
really see it very well but these this
is high and this is a step down here
okay so the so the water table is is
higher up and it comes down below those
basements so you've got this water
feeding in on a daily basis and so they
have to pull off four hundred metric
tons a day which when it gets into the
bay
it becomes contaminated and then they
have to clean it up so they put it in
these tanks and then they try to clean
it up but they can take everything out
except for the tritium and so you'd say
okay well it's just tritium just throw
it into the sea you know dilution is the
solution to pollution no no the
fishermen will not allow that and
they've running out of room it's it's a
real crisis and and one needs to think
about some of these things ahead of time
so that in the event of an accident
that's something that you're ready to do
something and you you also have to be
ready to communicate this okay so I'm
finally reaching the end here so I think
there's a lot that needs to be done to
address Fukushima and it's it's very
important to do show we've learned a lot
as a result of the accident will
continue to learn more as we can get
closer to looking at the the damaged
reactors themselves learn a lot on the
nuclear engineering side of things the
timeliness and the amount of response to
these issues by regulators and
especially the industry is going to be
essential in making the public trust
this industry to move forward it's going
to be a measure of credibility it's
going to be the basis of public trust to
do more or maintain nuclear power and so
I argue that will affect the the nuclear
power in the future and just to leave
you on a slightly lighter note i don't
know how well you can see this but this
is a tanker truck a gas tanker truck at
a at a nuclear power plant and it's got
a sign on it here that's a zero defect
delivery this doesn't engender trust so
so i leave you with the note that you
have to be credible ok I'll stop there
Alison thanks so much that was
absolutely terrific questions thank you
very much for a great presentation did I
understand correctly that if the genset
I mean their generators are backup
generators I've been positioned 15
meters above sea level with the fuel
supplies we wouldn't be talking about
Fukushima nowadays which brings the
second question is there a redundancy in
the backup systems that people are
devising now yes yes and yes so you know
I can't speak for every power plant in
the United States and I can only really
speak for the United States because I
don't know the details of what other
countries are doing but one of the
things the Nuclear Regulatory Commission
is looking for is backup diesel
generators backup systems that are
either in some kind of earthquake
protected building or distributed around
the site so that you know if some event
takes out the the diesel generator high
up there there's one lower down
something like that so yes hi I have a
somewhat off-topic question more about
security and clear fruition haha talk
about how much interaction there is
among the folks NRC who are regulating
electric nuclear power and the folks
you're regulating security of nuclear
weapons sites and considering when
nonviolent protesters including 80 year
old nuns repeatedly enter high-security
nuclear weapons sites I'd imagine that's
a real security and also public
relations concern for those trying to
manage the security of nuclear power
sites where there's spent fuel rods
whatnot right and how do what the
interaction is what the concerns are and
what's being done about them sure great
question and in terms of the degree of
interaction there
discussion but not a lot but after nine
eleven the Nuclear Regulatory Commission
made a lot of regulatory changes to make
plants much more secure and all the
plants I visited are very secure there
would not be any 82 year old nuns that
would make it to the reactor building
and start banging on it with a hammer
they wouldn't get close you have to go
through multiple fences there are guard
booths that are 60 feet high all around
the site with guards in them lots of
guns at most at many facilities many of
these plants thirty percent of the
workforce is security and my my view one
of the good things is a lot of the work
force works directly for the company
they are not subcontractors or
contractors which is the case at
oakridge and so I think that's that's a
real plus so I think that that the the
nuclear industry and the regulators have
done a lot to really secure plants they
also are required to every two or three
years every year they're supposed to do
force on force activities where they
pretend they're being attacked view the
Nuclear Regulatory Commission watches
and evaluates them every two or three
years and they're basically ex-navy
seals are brought in to challenge the
site with the latest technology that's
being used in whatever war were fighting
and and if they fail they are reported
to their governor and the reported to
Congress and that scares a lot of the
utilities enough that they actually
heavily invest in this security side so
i think the the model now that exists
for security at nuclear power facilities
in the u.s. is a very good one yeah i
saw your points well-taken about
counting other impacts obviously besides
just deaths and i don't think i was
implying that my talk for instance i
didn't cover psychological trauma from
the
chernobyl accident as well as morbidity
prevented morbidity in the calculations
that we did but in any case I think from
a scientific point of view we do have to
distinguish how much of the of those
adverse impacts resulted from the
radiation fallout per se versus the
government's reaction to what they
perceived as dangerous fallout why
because I mean some of those impacts
could have been avoided if the
government overreacted for instance okay
if the government overreacted how in
other words it perceived in a level of
radiation thought that was higher than
the threshold that would cause that's
known to cause health damages I mean
okay you see what I'm saying the
distinction between how much of it would
have been due to radiation fallout by
itself if for instance if no government
actions were taken versus how much was
due to the government policies that's
okay okay I don't know that there was a
strong government policy and I'm talking
about the evacuations for instance and
write those things I mean as I mentioned
the unsecured report on fukushima did
look at ecological effects and they
found only a temporary effect on
wildlife for instance at Fukushima yeah
and although i would say i would argue
you really don't have enough run time to
really know what the full scale of
environmental impacts will be I mean
you-you-you we are still trying to
understand the impacts on the coast and
the waters because there's a fair amount
of radioactivity there that's you know
collected in the sediments and the
impact that will have on marine life is
not clear yet local marine life it's
it's true that's the that's the word I
was going to use is local that's what
the you that's what the unsecured report
which remember is over 80 technical
experts right you know and like i said
but picture noble the impacts the
environmental impacts went very far I
mean they affected northern England
if I understood at the beginning of your
talk you said that there had been an
increase in earthquake activity in the
year there had been an increase in
earthquake activity in the years leading
up I thought you said there was some
previous earthquake in there was a
precursor a few days before there were
some foreshocks a few days before the
massive nine-point-oh that's all I said
sorry if I was unclear I thought the
answer to Sandra's question was the
facility would have survived the
earthquake itself do they have an
estimate do they have deep what we know
now you know and I don't know that we
know the full story but after the
earthquake occurred they lost off-site
power because of the shaking of the
earthquake all the reactors that were
operating shut down as they should and
that that work fine what we don't really
understand if is was was there some
earthquake damage that affected
especially unit one that I don't know
that we're going to be able to extract
very well so really it's an open
question to some degree hello I was just
wondering you said that we don't
currently have any filters on our vents
were like Silva Kia why is that why do
we not have it why do other countries do
are we doing something else to prohibit
that radioactivity no we're not uh you
know there was a there's a rulemaking
now which is I think having some trouble
but looking at alternative ways of
scrubbing and using a lot of human
operator operator actions to try to put
water into the containment to scrub and
basically knock out some of that
radioactivity into the water whether
that will work those containments are
pretty complex there's a lot of
equipment there how the water would be
sprayed and whether it would really work
well I think it's very difficult to
model
you're also very dependent on human
operator actions in a crisis and I think
that's a very uncertain thing to depend
on why not just put a little tank
outside but the industry was opposing
this because of supposedly the cost but
I'm not so sure about that because the
one of the TEPCO facilities the largest
nuclear power plant in the world the
cash iwasaki korea plants which has
seven reactors they've added filters
already quickly I wanted to follow up
with your question about oakridge but
also wanted to come back to Fukushima as
a character witness for that nun who
went into oak ridge in court it was
absolutely incredible to see the to
subcontractors total inefficiency total
absolute negligence in every possible
way so that you could say a year and a
half later we have safety is something
that we might be a little bit skeptical
about oh no no the safety at the nuclear
power plants was increased as a result
of 911 yeah so it was also supposed to
be after that particular event we may be
for the nuclear well i have i'd say
nothing about the nuclear weapons
complex I make no claims about the
nuclear weapons complex I am only
talking about nuclear reactors I
understand but they're not unrelated in
certain ways but the Fukushima a case as
a person who's lived in Japan for three
years of someone who studies Japan and
China for a long long time the prime
minister at the time as you may know was
concerned to evacuate in his words 50
million people on and he is now a very
strong opponent of nuclear power and the
nuclear industry as you know in in Japan
TEPCO and others have been anything but
clear and transparent just that you
pointed this out in terms of
communication but I think it would be
helpful to talk about the anti-nuclear
movement in Japan
record of safety which is not so great
and yet this is a country with high
technological competence and so on so
are you know are the record of these
companies in Japan and the way they've
bought out local communities with gems
and and other things is it's not very
reassuring let's just put it that way hi
Allison probs over out just a ring came
for another reason clown couldn't resist
speculate a little about what the United
States is going to do about a hundred
aging nuclear reactors post-fukushima is
also one hundred reactors getting a year
older every year some of the companies
wanting to shut them down even before
that their current licenses run out well
are we planning ahead for this sure sure
so with speculate a little bit about the
hundred aging reactors there 99 now
Vermont Yankee shut down it's it's an
interesting issue I think it's very
interesting and important issue so most
of the plants that have actually all of
the plants that have applied for license
extensions and I think there are like 73
or 74 of them receive them so they are
now licensed to operate out to 60 years
and so there are a few that are younger
plants that haven't yet applied for
those license extensions and there are
aging issues you know we see we've seen
in the past couple years now a couple
plants shut down because and we're
trying to replace parts steam generators
in the case of San Onofre plant in
California where the replacement part
was bad part and but of course an
extremely expensive part on the order of
a billion dollars for two steam
generators the the choice was to to shut
down and we saw a similar situation with
Crystal River plants in Florida so there
are important issues there that have to
be tracked some of the significant ones
is that
a lot of the piping and the electric
electrical supplies at the reactors are
buried and those are different you can't
see them so how do you evaluate their
performance over many decades and this
becomes especially significant in the
previous panel I think Dave Christian
mentioned now this push for reactors to
try to get license extensions out to 80
years I think that becomes more critical
when you know when they try to get that
and in particular I think arc of concern
to nuclear engineers that I've talked to
are these GE blowing water mark one and
Mark two plants because if they get
pushed out to 80 years you're talking
about a 100 year old design essentially
is that reasonable I don't know hi I
guess I have a question and then a
comment so you mentioned the hardened
vents over there I was wondering you
know where the regulations going with
regards to you know hardened Benson fuel
failure specifically like Japan I know
is crediting you know complete failure
of the fuel when they're regulating
bunkers building hardened bunkers to
shut down the plant and I was wondering
your feelings on the the Flex program so
i think the flex program which is the
additional backup equipment that's being
distributed around the plants and then
at those regional response centers I
think it's been pretty good the
industry's really put a lot of money
into that and they and they are going to
meet their 2016 deadline probably many
of them will meet at ahead of time so I
think that's been that's been very
worthwhile in terms of the hardened
vents now there's an order out to the
mark 1 and mark two reactors in the
country by the way there are 22 mark 1
reactors and eight mark two reactors
operating in the country and those are
required to harden their events and
they're working on that nail
I don't know that the NRC is going to
try to combine all of that together
right now so I was struck by your
comment about sort of the responsible
nature of placing the nuclear plant
where it was placed mm-hmm sort of
that's what you implied because they
didn't ever imagine a tsunami that sighs
I think they had a wall about 15 was it
15 I forgotten the number do you know
what the how high the wall was it was
like seven meters something like that
yeah 20 feet yeah and so number one you
know just from a geologist point of view
you build a plant on the side of the
subduction zone where a tsunami will
arrive and they have another side to the
island right so yeah but that's pretty
seismically active too okay but it
actually there isn't a subduction zone I
think in it no but it's still it's still
pretty seismically active are there is
their history of tsunamis on that side
of the onion I don't know actually and
but there are and I'm curious what the
what is the record of tsunami heights
from that area that they could glean not
just from oh it's recent right and so to
me the first thing I was struck by this
was how irresponsible it was to actually
place as I don't care you know whether
things have been happening last 10 20
years you're giving me a you know an
earth science perspective there's just
no way of predicting the magnitude of
that earthquake and putting it on that
side of the island and also having a
history of tsunamis with a particular
height that they could have predicted so
the first thing I would say is that
that's screwed up but also that if we're
doing anything similar it's screwed up
as well and I you know the first thing I
would think of is like Indian Point and
I know that that there's there's a fault
that runs right by that plant as well so
why wouldn't you want to learn from that
experience now and not we're in that you
know not lead yourself down to the road
of a disaster of course you couldn't
predict but it's a good likelihood to
occur
just because of the geology in the area
well I think you bring up a lot of good
points citing is important and you cite
with the knowledge that you have
unfortunately or fortunately knowledge
of geologic processes and natural
hazards has been increasing over time or
we we've learned a little more about how
the earthworks and we continue to learn
more about how the earth works now I
think the question then is how do you
incorporate that new knowledge in a
timely basis into your safety regime and
I think that's really where the rub is
right now and whether we're going to do
that and whether the Japanese are going
to do that you know they're looking
right now at whether there is a fault
that runs through a reactor facility
from a geologist point of view from my
point of view I don't know about rod but
I think whether the fault is runs right
under your building or runs 300 feet
away from your building it's kind of
irrelevant so I you know it but people
are met you know they're making these
these these judgments based on on issues
like that but I think it's I think it's
really essential that we at least in
this country and I was really pushing
for this at the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission I was getting a lot of
pushback from my colleagues but that we
revisit knowledge about natural hazards
on a periodic basis every 10 years we do
a seismic hazard analysis yeah just as a
follow-up comment on that the
seismologists will tell you that before
that earthquake there was good
theoretical and observational reason to
believe that an earthquake of magnitude
9 could not have occurred yeah on that
particular fault well I know they think
differently about it let me give you a
little more history of that uh before
the Sumatra quake the theory that that
held among the seismological community
was that only certain subduction zones
could create mega quakes quakes larger
than magnitude 8.8 in large part because
we hadn't seen that many on earth during
our very very very short
time here observing these things well
then there was the Sumatra quake there
was the Christchurch quake the Sumatra
Creek created this enormous tsunami
which killed you know 200,000 people or
more and then the seismologist said okay
whoops guess we better rethink this now
the accepted idea this was now probably
around 2,000 2007-2008 all subduction
zones of sufficient length can produce
mega quakes and then in 2011 we we get
another example of this so in some
senses you know how quickly does the
nuclear industry have to catch up to
this new knowledge is an important issue
just a you're given a choice from on
high do we keep nuclear power or do we
stop nuclear power in the United States
what's your answer if we stop nuclear
power tomorrow where would you get that
twenty percent 19 really twenty nineteen
percent of electricity you gonna as they
said I mean you're going to be up
unhappy when you can't charge your phone
well yes I'm asking you if you if
there's a choice because I mean there's
there's people in this country that want
to see nuclear end and then there's
people in this country that want to see
advanced Jenner imeem the generation 3
plus that with the ap1000 s and the
newer generations of machines come
online sometime soon and we gain an
active development forearm so in your in
your opinion do we go forward with new
killer I don't think I don't think we
pull the plug tomorrow I'll tell you
that much I think it's I think it's
complicated I think every people have
made excellent points today about how
nuclear is carbon free and really the
big problem facing the planet right now
is climate change and the sooner we get
on dealing with that the better and so
nuclear provides that carbon-free
electricity and we need that and it
provides base load in
we it's also going to depend on how
quickly we can get our grid up to speed
to deal with the renewables there we
need a lot of work the quadrennial
energy review just came out you know
we've got a decrepit old grid by the way
the grid was not designed to do what
it's being used to do now it was
designed as a backup system for the
nearby power plant it was not designed
to sell electricity made in Indiana out
to California that's ridiculous but
that's that's where we are so anyway I'm
going to take one last question I'd like
to rather than ask a question of dr.
MacFarlane because you did a great job
just make a couple of comments first of
all designs make a difference and
locations make a difference to try to
put a blanket statement across nuclear
power to say should we shut it down or
not we need to be very careful at
looking at each site and each design and
I think that's what the regulatory
commission has done I think that also
you need to explore reactors near
fukushima to see it's their individual
responses there were there was a dual
plant site sandai i thinks the name that
was actually closer to the epicenter but
they built a real one huh on akkalla
they built a really high sea wall they
had no problem actually the sister unit
to Fukushima Shima Thank You Nene
because of the reactions of the staff
prevented the same disaster happening
there so you can't make blanket
statements you have to look really
specifically and make choices and the
things that you do to improve
periodically the reactors make that a
big difference and that's luckily what
the US has been doing for decades you
know we I think that's a great point
Regis and we make too often especially
in this country but I think in many
places we fight the last war and you
know okay so we're ready to fight the
last war and
the new happens so for it for an example
one of the plants on the eastern coast
of Japan and I'm not going to remember
which one has built a new tsunami wall
it's 25 meters high it's a mile long
this thing cost a billion dollars can be
seen from space was it worth it did they
should they have done something else you
know put more backup equipment have new
procedures I'm not sure Allison thanks
very much for doing double duty and for